what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time on friday we
made it to the end of the week
thankfully she didn't kill me i'm still
here that's cause i'm tough
uh i'm here with the beautiful and
intelligent plana evilova marinova
pompliano
p-i-m-h she's got black but
maybe i should start going like in a
little little gun action
also i'm wearing um my earrings that my
friend kara got me for my birthday
when is my birthday the 21st ah
oh no no 24th 24th i remember i remember
thank you i have a whole plan this
weekend no worries i'm not telling
anybody
uh hey if you guys got any ideas let me
know um
lunch money is not sponsored by block
five block five has three products
but i'm only gonna talk about the
interest bearing account today because
you can deposit crypto or stable coin
and earn up to eight point six percent
interest
in a interest bearing account listen if
you put your
dollars into a bank account they pay you
0.03 or 0.05
right three to five basis points is what
they pay you
instead what you can get is you can earn
eight point six percent
up to eight point six percent in a block
five account go
check it out no brainer block five dot
com slash lunch money
no brainer i might just start saying
that all the time no brainer
get money get paid all right he wants to
hear that no-brainer
nobody wants to hear that okay so ready
yeah over a two-week span in early july
seven retailers oh no come on including
the paper store
brooks brothers and lucky brand filed
for bankruptcy protection
j crew neiman marcus and jcpenney and
four other retailers had already filed
in may
lord and taylor in the off-price shop
steinmart led another wave that hit
earlier this month
so basically all these retailers are
rushing to file for bankruptcy before
a second wave of covet happens no
brainer
oh my god of course they're filing for
bankruptcy
they were already dying people don't
want to go in the stores there's
something called the
internet the internet was decimating
them and now all of a sudden what you're
finding
is that kovid accelerated
what was already underway and people
can't go in the store so you can't go in
the store how you supposed to buy
anything you can't buy anything you
can't buy anything there's no revenue if
there's no revenue then there can be no
profits there's
no profits then how do you actually run
your business you can't
um the executive managing director of
tiger capital group said the challenge
is making sure we can actually close
stores in a window that is open
yeah well i mean that's a whole nother
thing if they don't even have enough
capital to actually get the
stores closed that's going to be pretty
crazy but look at the end of the day
uh there are four means before the
second wave hits oh that's a whole other
thing too but
uh there are many of these that will
actually not die
like they will just get restructured
they'll get uh equity will get wiped out
the bondholders will end up taking the
equity
uh they'll get new management in and
some of them will survive some of them
will go out of business and everyone
will lose everything
um but we'll see it's all right they're
all they're all private equity shops
that levered up with debt they'll be big
boys they'll be fun somebody said retail
darwin is almost accelerated because of
the pandemic whereby
certain species survived because they
were strong enough to others
have been weighed down by too much debt
did y'all hear what i just said
what basically that guy copied me i said
that's exactly what i just said i just
didn't use a big fancy word like
darwinism
all right you ready are you ready you're
clicking around a lot
don't we talk about my clicking okay
lyft and uber will not suspend their
ride-hailing services in california on
thursday at midnight after a state
appeals court ruled in their favor
regarding an
injunction against the companies the
move follows a court order in california
that requires the companies to
reclassify drivers as employees
can i go on my hot take rant go on
uber and lyft versus the us government
is the battle i'm here for governments
are notorious for being really good at
value destruction
they're horrible capital allocators
horrible
entrepreneurs on the other hand end up
being pretty good capital allocators
they're in the business of value
creation the state of california
is so bad at managing itself
that not only does it lose money left
right
and center but on top of that
people are leaving in droves literally
palantir palantir owned like all of palo
alto at one point in terms of all the
real estate they left california
tesla new factory not there there are
lots and lots of people who are
leaving california because california
believes
that the answer to their problems is
more regulation
and more taxes that is all
barked and no bite like so it's all fun
and games right until
lyft and uber like we will literally
leave your state like there will you
cannot call an uber here
to pick you up after you've been
drinking on a friday night well
it it goes back to two
simple principles one is rather than
trying to regulate the companies
just create a third category that's what
dara was saying people do yeah so they
have either you're
a contractor or you're an employee maybe
let's create a
gig worker so that then they can get
some of the benefits of an employee and
some of the benefits of a contractor and
make it work for both the
person who works there and also the
business by the way they're not
employees
it's very clear they're not employees
what job do you have
where you can at any time just click a
button on your phone and go home
if you're an employee you can't do that
and so of course they are contractors or
what they really are is they're gig
workers and so
you got to create a sandbox for them to
fit in
why why are the governments reluctant to
let the companies do this
other category have you seen
how absurd california is literally
remember this is the same state
where the mayor of los angeles said if
you have a party
we're going to shut off your power and
elect and your water
these people are idiots and
i'll go a step further uber and lyft
called their bluff
and the government caved the courts
not just yet i mean they gave us no they
said they said last night at midnight
they're going to shut the services and
all of a sudden things got done
so uber and lyft called the bluff and
the court system or the government
whoever is the person
responsible they actually caved
of course they did because all bark and
no bite and this is
the government is acting like the mafia
acts it basically is saying
you can't do that unless you pay us
that's what's happening
and the company said cool then we just
won't do it then we won't operate
but literally you're going to get people
killed that's that's the argument i
would be saying if i was uber and lyft
you're going to get people killed
because we know that when uber and lyft
go into a city the number of drunk
driving
deaths plummets because people aren't
driving drunk as often
so what we have here is a classic
example
of where a government is stepping in and
by intervening they believe that they're
actually providing
more value but instead what they're
doing is they are completely destroying
value
just let the companies
operate and if you want to do your job
create a third category
of a gig worker it's not that hard that
was a good that was a good rant are you
ready it just pisses me off
when people end up going after these
companies
and they force them do you think that
uber and lyft want to do this do you
think they want to have a showdown
do you think they want to have to
threaten this to get rid of the service
like that hurts their reputation right
but it's simply just the ineptitude oh
man i'd be a
savage if i was the ceo of uber or lyft
you don't want me you don't want me
there my biggest piece of advice to dara
is you should start engaging in meme
warfare meme
warfare first yeah we need i i'm here
for the dara
versus gavin newsom memes
i feel like did you see gavin newsom the
other day he was standing in the woods
he's the governing council
he's standing in the woods like climate
change is real come to california and
you could see the climate change
you could see it yeah like he's like if
you don't believe in climate change just
come to california
okay ready the justice department has
filed charges against
uber's former security chief for
allegedly attempting to conceal a 2016
hack
that exposed the email addresses and
phone numbers of 57
million drivers and passengers
prosecutors accused joseph sullivan who
was uber's chief security officer
of not disclosing the hack to federal
investigators who were looking into
another data breach
that had occurred two years earlier what
do you think about this so basically his
crime is that he knew about it and he
did not disclose it
right uh i think that what they're
saying is not only did he know about it
and not disclose it but there was some
allegedly tried allegedly they tried to
actively conceal it i don't know enough
about this to comment
i really don't like when uh things are
written
in a way where somebody who's accused of
something is automatically assumed
guilty
okay but okay so also in 2016 hackers
obtained access to uber's user data and
asked for a six-figure ransom
sullivan and other uber executives
allegedly negotiated a hundred thousand
dollar bitcoin payment
in december 2016 and asked the hackers
to sign non-disclosure
non-disclosure agreements allegedly but
here's the but here's like the whole
point right
so that sentence makes it seem like
there was a bunch of people who got
together and did this
why did they only go after one person
then because he was in charge
maybe but other uber executives okay
maybe the
you know they're that means that they're
his peers okay it doesn't matter
what matters is this is happening yeah
what is your thoughts in terms of good
bad i mean i i do agree with this
silicon valley is not the wild west the
u.s attorney david anderson said that i
think that's a pretty good we expect
good corporate citizenship i i would
yeah i i mean we expect prompt reporting
of criminal conduct we expect
cooperation with our investigations we
will not operate
tolerate corporate cover-ups we will not
tolerate illegal hush money payments i
think everything he just said there
is super legit right so if you're doing
that i i really like the phrase hush
money for some reason
why hush money it's like hush puppy
no brainer all right moving on that's
just a sad story by the way
what is the hush movie no no the uh uber
thing
why because it's just like it it's
really hard to know right now what's
true what's not true whatever's
allegations
all this kind of stuff but it's just
like there was a bad situation
and if what's being alleged is true it's
like they made it worse right like there
was
uh a breach of information and rather
than reporting it
instead if there was a cover up like i
don't know it's just you don't like to
hear that so like
you just want the entrepreneurs go focus
on building the business stop dealing
with all the crazy stuff well he's not
exactly an entrepreneur if he was
working at a
big well i'm just saying like okay the
executives
over 50 billion dollars of
cryptocurrency moved from
china-based digital wallets to other
parts of the world in the last year
pointing to possibilities that chinese
investors are transferring more money
than allowed out of the country
a new report claims china chain analysis
did this report
i wrote about this today oh did you yes
shares that you read here's my thing
it's 50 billion dollars of
cryptocurrency billion billion
yeah and what they did is they looked at
people that they know have the wallets
in china moving to things outside of
china
fine i actually think that that's great
that you can monitor it
uh or not that you can monitor it but
the fact that you can measure that
sure that's all fair game where they get
into this game of
oh it's because they're avoiding capital
controls how do you know
and by the way uh chain analysis who
created a report they say this in the
report
so it's the headline that's super
misleading why is they basically say
look
all you can infer from this number is
that the maximum amount of
money that's being used to avoid capital
controls
could be 50 billion but we have no clue
what percentage of that 50 billion is
avoiding capital controls versus let's
say just sending money to somebody
using it for a business transaction uh
speculators trading otc
trades like all that you just don't know
and so that could be any bigger
number it could be zero percent trying
to avoid capital control right right
right you're saying like the re we know
how much but we don't know the reasons
behind it of course
and so some people will argue that
that's a good thing that we don't know
the reasons right because it was a
payment processor
that was centralized they could tell us
exactly what the money was being used
for
or if it other people argue that uh
we really need to know this information
but whatever but i think so i think this
is interesting chinese citizens are only
allowed to buy up to fifty thousand
dollars a foreign currency a year at a
financial institution
in the past wealthy citizens have
circumvented the limit
to foreign investment in real estate and
other assets but the government has
cracked down on these methods
according to a report by chain analysis
so i i really do think that like
crypto could be making up for the fact
that they can't do these other methods
you know that uh those capital controls
are the reason why
new york real estate is uh falling
through the floor
really yeah why you want to hear a crazy
story
no here we go ready so you have lipstick
on your teeth
yeah from two nope still there okay uh
from 2012 i think it was
like 2016 or 17. uh there was massive
capital inflows from foreign investors
and they were buying up
especially chinese uh nationals
especially they were buying up
uh all kinds of um apartments and stuff
in new york
and so developers saw this massive uh
capital inflow so they started to build
and they built so fast but it still took
them like 18 months to
two years by the time that those uh
pieces of
uh property started coming online and
actually being able to
lease out then the capital investment
numbers had gone down
uh because of there was stricter capital
controls in china
and so now there's a bunch of unfilled
inventory sitting in new york prices
have to come down in order to get people
to take it
so actually what ends up happening is uh
crypto could be saving new york real
estate
how do we get from there to there the
transitive property
a equals b if b equals simulation you
mean
no what's the next one oh i had to crack
my knife okay come on this isn't a
massage [ __ ] so um you just told me i
had lipstick on my teeth
so looking out for you oh thank you i
appreciate it so
apparently in cove at times so i have a
much younger sister who's
in high school right now and she told me
about this that
schools are making kids
adhere to the school dress code while at
home on
zoom over school education they're lucky
i wasn't in school during this are you
kidding me
so apparently the it won high school for
example the standard pre-covered dress
code mandated that pants must be worn at
the waist
head apparel cannot be worn inside
skirts dresses and shorts
must be beyond finger tip length and
students cannot wear pajamas or blankets
during class
so my sister told me about the pajamas
thing she was like what
i wear a shirt as pajamas how are they
gonna
i was like okay anyway oversized kids
are wearing pajamas
like you know well i guess i don't know
the fact that they had to actively state
it
means that some kids are probably
wearing pajamas on zoom i didn't see in
the rules
you have to wear a shirt that's not in
the rules
okay see this is why i was great in high
school that's not in the rules
oh my god so they have all those rules
but doesn't say you have to wear a shirt
i don't even know so i would go without
a shirt and they'd be like you're
breaking another bike it's not in the
rules but it's just so ridiculous like
you can only see
like here to here and if you're lucky i
mean somebody it doesn't say you have to
wear a shirt okay
so it talks about your skirt length but
it doesn't talk about your shirt yeah
welcome to being a girl i'm just saying
um so anyway it's just i mean it's
ridiculous this is why they should have
the kids write the rules
at the same time i kind of get it like
you don't want to be seeing people with
like blankets wrapped around their face
why who cares well it's you know
who cares you got you you show up you're
showing up to an
educational experience you got to be
presentable
what come on these kids would get better
education on the internet
we know we know all right what's next
gronk gronk rob gronkowski went fishing
and accidentally he's such an adept
fisherman that he accidentally caught a
big
shark look at how big the shark is hold
on a second
look at this shark yeah it's a big ass
shark
of course he caught a shark so he was
like all right and then he
said he posted a video of him it says
shark fiesta
then siesta he's sleeping on the
shoulder of his buddy
is that him or is that him uh i think
this is him no
oh he's on the right okay he's the guy
who's six five
i can't tell they're sitting uh so
i mean look they have a logo of a shark
on his shirt so something tells me that
they went shark fishing oh you think
yes oh no oh yeah well they let it go
but it still can't be nice for the shark
to have that
hook in your mouth what are you standing
up for the fish now oh yeah i'm a big
fish
conservative no um
activist okay you saw lipstick on your
teeth
i hate you no brainer
what's your joke come on hurry up this
this show i'm getting bored let's go
what do you call someone wearing a belt
with a watch on it
a belt with a watch on it
oh man i just thought of something not
so appropriate i don't know what
a waste of time
do you remember the belts that you could
have messages go by on them oh
no i do not oh yeah you could oh my god
no and they would have like this digital
thing and you could make it say whatever
you wanted my friend had one
he used to wear the parties and i
remember just being like bro where'd you
get that he was like spencer's oh
spencer's i did not associate with kids
who shopped at spencer i
loved spencer you get all kinds of
watching what was the other one hot
topic
no hot topic was a little weirder oh
wait i thought i thought that was like
kind of the same thing what was
spencer's
spencer's was where you could get all
like the games and the and the tricks
and toys
and the inappropriate t-shirts and no
hot topic was like the
goth okay i didn't associate with either
person probably i was one of those
people who had like the neck
uh the neck thing on with the spikes
coming out of it
all right guys that's it for lunch
monday today while wash is trying to get
rich rest of us just trying to get our
lunch money right
get money get paid stay safe have a
great weekend we'll talk to you guys on
monday
do i sell lipstick yes oh bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends